did you guys hear about the fact that
youtube is a proven juggernaut that
rivals
netflix in the streaming views let me
give you some stats on this so google
parent company alphabet delivered
another monster earnings
report tuesday one of the brightest bits
came from youtube which booked a
whopping
ready seven billion dollars in
advertising revenue last quarter
quarterly revenue is on par
with netflix and it's growing at a
faster rate alphabet said youtube
booked 7 billion in ad revenue last
quarter that's 83
from a year ago compared to compare that
to
netflix's 7.3 billion dollars in revenue
booked in the same period netflix's
revenue grew 19.4
from a year ago by the way that's is
that not interesting to know that
youtube grew by 83 percent
versus netflix is 19 that's wow that
that's pretty well to think with youtube
television viewing has grown
faster than ever before the company said
120 million people watch
youtube on tv last month
up from 100 million per uh month last
year
uh up from a 100 million a month from
last year's 20
youtube's tick tock rival is also
growing short-term video is the dominant
trend on social media today
with tocks leading on charge youtube has
its own short term uh short form video
service youtube shorts
designed to compete with tick tock
alphabet didn't disclose how many people
are using youtube shorts but said
viewing metrics jumped from 6.5 billion
views per day
in march to 15 billion views a day in
the end of last quarter so youtube
beating netflix tom are you surprised by
this
no we kind of talked about a little bit
of this we were talking about disney
plus like about a month and a half ago
here on the podcast
so remember covid year spurred
everything and the disney plus launch
happened
at the you know orgasmic perfect
launch point for disney plus for
everybody was in the house
and everybody wanted to watch tv and
disney plus was a fan
with hulu was a great over-the-top uh
service well i think what's also
happening is you gotta remember we're
talking about the youtube viewership
that's web
online ad supported over the last course
of the last year
so it doesn't surprise me and i'm i'm
really seeing
you know yet abc nbc cbs and i that was
the original big three
before the consolidations and cw went
away and fox remember all that
well i think what you have right now
you've got the disney monolith
you have youtube because remember as
youtube television as well as youtube
online
et cetera and then you've got um you
know
tick tock and i think what's interesting
about tick tock what we kind of
jumped over and i don't know if you guys
covered this or not tick tock is only
the second
company ever to have three billion
downloads right facebook was number one
tick tock was number two
my understanding and so i think the
plates are shifting and what we're
seeing is a big
three emerge in both streaming and
entertainment disney plus and hulu
and then youtube with youtube tv
and then you've got you know snap's not
really doing its thing you have facebook
instagram
waiting in the lobby to go into congress
sir and um
and then tick tock that's what i think
is going on we're seeing big three
emerge
like we've seen in other industries i
think um
well look there's there's two different
sides of this there's two different
things at play
all right there is the idea of a model
right you have the two different models
you have the subscription versus the
freemium model
but then you also have the restriction
of speech
and curation versus choice right like if
you go on netflix especially over the
last two
three years uh it's been remarkably
um look it's basically social
engineering right i mean the amount of
we talk about all the time and i know
i'm sounding like johnny right wing
again but it's just this is the truth of
it like
everything has a left wing
progressive messaging so it turns people
off if i go to a netflix original i just
immediately think okay it's going to be
orange is the new black it's going to be
this it's going to be that it's going to
have the same messaging i'm not
interested in it
what are they telling me what what
concept are they selling kind of the
same thing with disney plus on
youtube i have the choice then like i
can watch what they what they suggest
but i have the choice to search for
anything that i want i'm on youtube all
the time and i find myself on tik tok
all the time now as well that algorithm
gets to know you pretty pretty well so
you're you're finding something
you know in our industry it's really
interesting because you know we're in
the content creation industry
how do you create an environment where
people are willing to pay
for content when they've grown their
entire life being entertained for free
and also how do you present them with
content when they themselves have chosen
the content that they want their whole
life
this is how itunes changed the game and
this is how youtube is
defeating netflix long-term who wins
netflix or youtube i think free choice
wins man
the the ability to choose exactly what
you want to watch
when you want to watch and to be able to
watch it for free
is it's an unbeatable i don't think
long-term netflix or youtube wins folks
if you're watching this long term who
wins
netflix or youtube i think you're right
we're talking about two different things
we're talking about long-form creation
and episodical that netflix does which
takes longer to build
millions and millions and millions of
dollars per new show concept
versus independently ran channels where
people are creating their own correct
yeah so who wins long term uh youtube
youtube on that platform wins long term
and i think they're going to find out
pretty quick that they need to allow the
conservative
voice a little bit more latitude and i
think they're going to learn that thanks
to the
facebook hearings that are coming up you
think so because right now they're
probably sitting there saying our
strategy's working we're up 83
you don't know what you're talking about
19 no no no netflix is up 19
youtube is up 83 do you think youtube is
saying tom our strategy is working well
everybody was talking about netflix a
year ago we're whooping their ass
they're at 19. we're doing 4x what
they're doing
and more so yes we're going to stick to
it the strategy is working well and
you're absolutely correct yeah
and but let's rewind a bit make sure
everybody hears what i just said
facebook is heading into hearings right
they're coming yeah
you've got all the new people that are
chairing ftc and you hear the statements
they're making even yesterday yeah
uh those people are not not happy with
facebook and the targeting
and facebook is trying to pander to the
americans
by writing a foil board with an american
flag while
john denver music plays right so i
i think right now or youtube's sales
executives
thinking no they're exactly what you're
saying pat you're right
but are they strategically thinking we
better keep our eye on this uh
government thing because if facebook
gets moved on this then they're gonna
move us too
we've actually seen this play out guys
but long term it's an open
field even if they censor it later it's
an open field netflix is a cd
you might have one show that you really
want on netflix you want to watch house
and cars so you've got netflix yeah
same way when when i wanted i wanted to
listen to rough rider's anthem i had to
buy
it's dark and hell's hot i had to buy
dmx's whole cd right that's netflix you
got to buy the platform to get that one
show
where i see youtube as itunes i could
just pick the one thing that i like and
i don't and then i'll go to something
else so
we saw this play out itunes destroyed
the cd industry there's no cds anymore
you don't need to buy a whole i think
that's a great
metaphor that's that's where we're at
we've seen i think it's
you know so long although every time
every now and then
netflix does something good like drive
to survive so so so
question go for your question question
it's unscripted
who is less likely to have a competitor
take
market share away from them okay
facebook
youtube or twitter who is the least
likely to have a direct competitor and
take market share away from i'm talking
a good amount of market share
youtube least likely i think so least
likely because the amount of server
space you would have to have to compete
is like remarkable you'd have to like
kind of like competing against a
bottling company like pepsi or coke yeah
okay so who's second least likely do you
agree with them by the way youtube being
number one
yes okay who's your second least likely
facebook or twitter
facebook facebook is second so twitter
is easier to go up against than facebook
or youtube
put it this way facebook tried to
compete with youtube twice they had
facebook watch
and they had igtv they tried to roll out
not one but two
different ips just to try to match
youtube and they they they failed
you agree with them every you agree with
them yes i do
what do you in the middle of an argument
you can add to that is
they were also the first one with the
big bank going out to pay creators
mm-hmm well well facebook tried to
facebook
talk about the place yeah had the big
bank they were like three xing the cpms
they were literally
gonna spend a half a billion dollars
five million at a time on a hundred
different shows remember that yep
and they and they went over to wme and
wme happily took the money so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye